and every single person that's made it
to the absolute top has lost way more
than they've won I lose every day me too
if I could just somehow through another
piece of content get people to like
themselves more stop beating themselves
up more everybody is going to deal with
pain everybody is going to do a
challenge everybody's going to deal with
struggle a lot of it probably that
person that you're envying or jealous of
right now is dealing with that you
have no idea and every single person
that's made it to the absolute top has
lost way more than they've won yep where
people miss it and this is important
Nuance they've micro lost not macro lost
because people want it so fast they take
these big risks that they can macro lose
but to your point I mean I lose every
day me too it's just a real thing yeah